DEATH OF THE REVEREND BILLY
GRAHAM.
THIS IS "SPECIAL REPORT" ."
GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO WASHINGTON.
I AM BRET BAIER.
ONE WEEK AFTER THE DEADLY
SHOOTING AT US HOW FOR THE
HIGH SCHOOLER CLAIM 17 LIVES,
AND FOREVER CHANGED MANY TIMES
THAT.
SURVIVORS BROUGHT THEIR DEMAND
FOR NEW GUN CONTROLS A NEW
SECURITY MEASURES TO THE STATE
CAPITAL IN TALLAHASSEE.
MEANWHILE, HERE IN WASHINGTON,
MOMENTS AGO, PRESIDENT TRUMP
FINISHED UP WHAT THE WHITE HOUSE
BILLED AS A LISTENING SESSION
EXCHANGE OF IDEAS AND EMOTION.
WHERE FOX TEAM COVERAGE TONIGHT.
STEVE HARRIGAN IS IN PARKLAND,
FLORIDA, WITH THE STUDENTS'
STORY DOWN THERE.
WE START OFF WITH CHIEF
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS ON THE NORTH LAWN.
>> GOOD EVENING.
IT WAS ANOTHER EXTRA IN A MOMENT
AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
THE NATION ALLOWED TO LISTENING
TO STUDENTS FROM DOUGLASS HIGH
AND THE PARENT OF ONE OF THE
CHILDREN KILLED THERE APPEALED
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP TO NOT LET
THE DOUGLAS SCHOOL SHOOTING BE
LIKE ALL THE OTHERS THIS NATION
HAS SEEN.
TO ACTUALLY MAKE A DIFFERENCE
THIS TIME.
IN THE STATE DINING ROOM TODAY,
SIX STUDENTS FROM DOUGLAS
HIGH SCHOOL AND THEIR PARENTS
COME ABROAD TO WASHINGTON BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
>> NOTHING EVER THAT HORRIBLE
SHOULD EVER HAVE TO HAPPEN TO
YOU.
>> I WAS LUCKY ENOUGH TO COME
HOME FROM SCHOOL.
MAYBE COMPROMISE ON SOME
SOLUTION SO THIS NEVER HAPPENS.
NO CHILD, NO PERSON IN THIS
WORLD WILL HAVE TO GO THROUGH
SOMETHING SO HORRIFIC.
>> THE SOLUTION IS NOT GOING TO
BE SINGULAR.
IT'S GOING TO BE MULTIFACETED.
>> IT IS NOT LEFT OR RIGHT, NOT
POLITICAL.
IT'S A HUMAN ISSUE.
>> I CAN'T UNDERSTAND WHY I CAN
STILL GO IN A STORE AND BUY THEM
BACK A WEAPON OF WAR.
>> STORIES OF THE TERROR.
FOR THE FATHER OF MEADOW
POLLACK, THE ANGUISH AND ANGER
OF A PARENT WHO WILL NEVER SEE
THEIR CHILD AGAIN.
>> THERE SHOULD'VE BEEN ONE
SCHOOL SHOOTING AND WE SHOULD
HAVE FIXED IT.
AND I AM PISSED.
IT'S MY DAUGHTER I AM NOT GOING
TO SEE AGAIN.
SHE IS NOT HERE.
SHE IS AT KING DAVID CEMETERY.
>> ALSO PARENTS OF CHILDREN
KILLED AT SANDY HOOK ELEMENTARY,
THE PARENTS OF RACHEL SCOTT, THE
FIRST STUDENT KILLED AT
COLUMBINE AND STUDENTS AND
TEACHERS FROM D.C. HIGH SCHOOLS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS A LISTENING
MODE BUT ALSO COMING TO THE
MEETING WITH IDEAS OF HIS OWN.
>> President Trump: WE ARE
GOING TO BE VERY STRONG ON
BACKGROUND CHECKS.
VERY STRONG ON BACKGROUND
CHECKS.
STRONG EMPHASIS ON THE MENTAL
HEALTH.
WE'RE GOING TO DO PLENTY OF
OTHER THINGS.
>> BEFORE PRESIDENT TRUMP
CONVENED THE MEETING, PROTESTERS
MARCHED THROUGH WASHINGTON TO
THE WHITE HOUSE TO OBSERVE A
MOMENT OF SILENCE.
TO READ THE NAMES OF THE FALLEN.
AND TO DEMAND THE PRESIDENT DO
SOMETHING CONCRETE TO ADDRESS
THE EPIDEMIC OF SCHOOL AND MASK
SHOOTINGS IN AMERICA.
-- MASS SHOOTINGS IN AMERICA.
>> WE NEED COMMON SENSE GUN
CONTROL LEGISLATION NOW.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP PLEDGED THE
DOUGLAS SCHOOL SHOOTING WILL BE
LIKE THE OTHERS, THAT IT WILL
RESULT IN CHANGES.
AMONG THE THINGS HE IS
CONSIDERING: RAISING THE FEDERAL
MINIMUM AGE TO BUY A RIFLE FROM
18.
KEEPING GUNS OUT OF THE HANDS OF
PEOPLE WHO SHOULD NEVER OWN
THEM.
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE OF MENTAL
ILLNESS AND TIGHTENING UP
BACKGROUND CHECKS TO MAKE SURE
RED FLAGS DON'T FALL THROUGH THE
CRACKS.
THE PRESIDENT ALSO SUGGESTED
MILITARY VETERANS COULD BE HIRED
TO PROVIDE SECURITY IN SCHOOLS.
>> YOU WOULD HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO WOULD BE ARMED,
READY, THEY MAY BE
PROFESSIONALS.
THEY MAY BE MARINES WHO LEFT THE
MARINES, LEFT THE ARMY, LEFT THE
AIR FORCE.
THEY ARE VERY ADAPTED DOING THAT
THEY ARE VERY ADAPTED DOING THA
THAT.
YOU'D HAVE A LOT OF THEM AND
THEY WOULD BE SPREAD EVENLY
THROUGHOUT THE SCHOOLS.
>> JUST THE FIRST LISTENING
SESSION THE PRESIDENT WILL HAVE
THIS WEEK.
TOMORROW HE MEETS WITH STATE AND
LOCAL OFFICIALS.
NEXT WEEK HE MEETS WITH THE
NATION'S GOVERNORS TO TALK ABOUT
THE PROBLEM.
BRET, WE'VE BEEN HERE MANY TIMES
IN THE PAST BUT AT LEAST ON THE
SURFACE, THIS TIME IS BEGINNING
TO FEEL DIFFERENT.
>> Bret: DEFINITELY DIFFERENT.
WE WILL SEE WHERE THIS GOES.
JOHN, ANOTHER TOPIC.
WE HEARD FROM WHITE HOUSE CHIEF
OF STAFF JOHN KELLY ABOUT
SECURITY CLEARANCES SPECIFICALLY
DEALING WITH JARED KUSHNER.
>> LAST FRIDAY CHIEF OF STAFF
JOHN KELLY SHARED A FIVE PAGE
MEMORANDUM SAME PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SECURITY CLEARANCES PENDING AS
OF JUNE 1 OR PRIOR WILL LOSE
THEIR INTERIM SECURITY CLEARANCE
AS OF THIS FRIDAY.
THAT APPARENTLY DOES NOT APPLY
TO JARED KUSHNER.
CHANGES MADE IN THE CLEARANCE
FORM, THE BACKGROUND FORM YOU
FILL OUT TO GET YOUR FULL
SECURITY CLEARANCE, THAT WAS NOT
SUBMITTED UNTIL AFTER JUNE 1.
CHIEF OF STAFF JOHN KELLY SAID
AND PRESS SECRETARY SARAH
HUCKABEE SANDERS SAID JARED
KUSHNER WILL CONTINUE TO FULFILL
HIS JOB WHICH INVOLVES LOOKING
AT SOME OF THE MOST HIGHLY
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION THAT
PASSES THROUGH THE WHITE HOUSE.
KELLY SAID HE'S GOING TO REVIEW
IT EVERY MONTH OR SO.
IF KUSHNER DOES NOT GET HIS FULL